und jetzt schauen wir in die Hauptstadt
schauen auf die Bilder die für uns von
dort erreichen aus Kiew aus der Nacht
und aber auch zum Beispiel hier gestern
Abend Paul ronsheimer während er mit uns
spricht hinter ihm die Einschläge hinter
ihm sieht man wie dort die Flammen
zucken dass also der Nachthimmel über
Kiew und wir sehen auch wie Paul dort
selber zusammenzuckt dir das aber
eigentlich schon fast muss man sagen
tragischerweise gewohnt ist ja auch die
Berichterstattung wird also immer
gefährlicher das haben ja die Aufnahmen
schon am Wochenende gezeigt die uns Paul
geschickt hat von dem Kollegen der dort
so schwer verletzt wurde als er raus
wollte aus irpinal Kiew dort als er dort
gefilmt hat in nahe dieser
fluchtkorridore ist eben auch er selbst
beschossen verletzt worden paul war ganz
in der Nähe hat uns diese Bilder
mitgebracht und jetzt gibt es schon
während wir hier berichten die nächsten
Meldung von einem offenbar in diesem
kriegsreportereinsatz verletzten
Kollegen von Fox News dem Reporter
Benjamin Brawler sei in der Ukraine
verletzt worden das hat FOX News bekannt
geworden berichtet oder informiert die
eigenen Mitarbeiter und schreibt dort an
die lieben Kollegen heute früh wurde
unser Korrespondent Benjamin Hall
verletzt dass er außerhalb von Kiew in
der Ukraine Nachrichten sammelte im
Moment haben wir da wenige Details
darüber wenn es im Krankenhaus unsere
Teams arbeiten daran weitere
Informationen zu sammeln die sei im
Moment unübersichtlich die Situation
schreibt Fox News über diesen jetzt
verletzten Verwundeten Kollegen dort in
der Ukraine und wir schauen jetzt direkt
nach Kiew zu Paul ronsheimer seit Wochen
für uns in der Ukraine unterwegs und er
steht vor dem Wohnhaus das heute in der
Nacht getroffen wurde wieder einmal Paul
ein ziviles Ziel wieder einmal Menschen
die nichts mit diesem Krieg zu tun haben
wollen die jetzt vor dem Trümmern ihres
zu Hause stehen
ja Patricia genauso ist es dieses
Wohnhaus 20 Minuten vom Zentrum entfernt
und es ist nur eines von mehreren Zielen
das in der Nacht und am Morgen getroffen
wurde wir haben hier bislang nichts über
Opfer gehört also nichts über Verletzte
oder tote gestern gab es ja mehrere Tote
und mehrere Verletzte möglicherweise war
es so dass eben aus diesem Haus bereits
viele Anwohner geflüchtet waren ohnehin
in Sicherheit waren aber es ist eine
ähnliche Wohngegend das ist podil eine
beliebte Wohngegend man hört übrigens im
Hintergrund auch gerade wieder das
Donnern von Grad aber in dem Fall
outgoing natürlich greifen auch Ukraine
von von Stellung weiter raus aus dem
Wohngebiet russische Stellung an das ist
ein Krieg der hier tobt natürlich ihr
habt gerade über Benjamin Hall
gesprochen ich habe von einem Freund
erfahren von einem guten Freund aus
diesem Team dass Sie davon ausgehen dass
er überleben wird das ist momentan der
Stand dass die Hoffnung es ist nichts
definitiv in diesem Krieg und ich will
euch einmal hier kurz mitnehmen einfach
runter die Straße zusammen mit Jorges
montafis der diese Kamera bedient wo ihr
diese Bilder sehen könnt und wir sehen
hier wieder die Zerstörung das ist ein
Bild geworden mit dem wir jeden Morgen
hier mittlerweile Aufwachen Link hier
man schaut auf sein Handy man ruft
Kollegen an ob sie etwas gehört haben
dann gibt es Meldungen ja wieder ein
Schüsse wieder Raketen auf Wohnhäuser
und man darf das man kann es gar nicht
oft genug betonen Patricia und Kai
wladimir Putin hat vor 20 Tagen gesagt
man würde nur militärische Ziele
attackieren das hat er mehrfach wieder
und jetzt reißt kurz die Schalter zu
Paul Abwehr arbeiten noch mal kurz da
dran das sind die Bilder unmittelbar
nach einer neuen raketennacht dort in
Kiew Paul dort vor diesem völlig
zerstörten Wohnblock und während wir mit
ihm sprechen fallen immer wieder Teile
dort von dem Balkon runter es wird
aufgeräumt dass es was was mich in
diesen Tagen ja irritiert und einer
andererseits macht irgendwie ein
bisschen Zuversicht dass die Menschen
dort daran glauben dass das
möglicherweise Paul du bist zurück auch
wieder vorbei geht da wird aufgeräumt
das ist also nicht die komplette Aufgabe
dort wird versucht die Trümmer zu
beseitigen die Wohnung wieder ja kann
man das sagen bewohnbar zu machen
ob da wieder etwas bewohnbar ist das
weiß ich nicht das sieht schon sehr
heftig zerstört aus wobei man sagen muss
dass die Zerstörung auch immer noch
heftiger sein können was wir hören ist
dass die explodieren dass sozusagen die
Rakete nicht komplett explodiert ist
sondern nur Teile davon ansonsten ähm
wäre dieses Hochhaus wohl noch
beschädigt da wir wissen aber von
anderen Einschlägen in der Stadt auch
wir wurden geweckt um 5 Uhr morgens mit
einer
wahnsinnigen Knall mit einer
wahnsinnigen Explosion die wir in der
Lautstärke zumindest inside Kiew also in
Kiew so noch nicht erlebt hatten und man
muss eines festhalten dass dieser Krieg
umkehrt immer heftiger wird bei allen
Debatten um angebliche
Friedensgespräche die ja bislang zu gar
nichts geführt haben muss man sagen die
Situation hier on the ground also die
Situation hier in Kiew zeigt dass dieser
Krieg immer weiter tobt
jetzt haben wir eben gerade bevor wir
gesprochen haben Paul wo mir silensky
gesehen den ukrainischen Präsident der
die russischen Soldaten aufgefordert hat
aufzugeben und ihm in das Versprechen
gegeben hat man werde sie behandeln wie
Menschen etwas was sie in ihrer Armee so
nicht kennen würden was glaubst du wie
sehr wird bei den russischen Soldaten
die ja auch vor der Herausforderung
stehen überhaupt weiterzumachen
teilweise völlig unerfahren sind und
auch den Widerstand der Ukrainer völlig
unterschätzt haben inwieweit werden Sie
vielleicht dieser bitte auch nachkommen
das kann ich nicht abschätzen das ist
natürlich nicht so leicht für
russische Soldaten da rauszukommen und
zu sagen wir geben jetzt auf da bräuchte
es sozusagen von hohen Rängen
Entscheidungen dass man die Waffen
niederlegt das halte ich stand jetzt für
eher unrealistisch aber natürlich kann
man sich vorstellen dass auch in der
russischen Armee da große Fragezeichen
sind warum sie hier ihr Leben riskieren
müssen warum so viele von ihnen sterben
wofür das alles wenn man das überhaupt
so sagen darf gut sein soll was das Ziel
ist also viele russische Soldaten so
hört man zumindest aus diesen Gesprächen
aus diesem Gesprächen aus diesem
Gesprächen verstehen es selbst nicht was
das ganze soll und ja das ist etwas was
die Hoffnung von würde mir selenski ist
aber wir sehen gleichzeitig wie die
Angriffe er brutaler werden also dass
die russische Armee mit den Bodentruppen
zwar nicht weiter unbedingt jede Stadt
reingeht aber dass man dann mit
Artillerie mit Raketen einfach in die
Städte feiert auch mit Streumunition was
für ein Haken gesehen haben also das
könnte jetzt die Strategie sein nachdem
die erste Strategie des schnellen
Angriffs und der schnellen Eroberung
nicht geklappt hat auch die zweite
Strategie nämlich der versucht mit einer
umfassenden Offensive alle Städte zu
umzingeln und einzunehmen nicht
funktioniert hat jetzt die dritte
Strategie folgen könnte nämlich ein
brutaler Krieg ein brutaler langer Krieg
mit Streumunition mit billigen Waffen
und das bedeutet noch mehr zivile Opfer
das wäre der Horror auch für die
Hauptstadt Kiew nachdem wir solche
Bilder ja du hast es gerade gesagt genau
aus Haken in der Nacht auch wieder
gesehen haben mit diesem Clusterbomben
gib uns einmal vielleicht wenn du kannst
einen größeren Überblick über die Stadt
also wir sehen dich jetzt in diesen
Tagen immer vor diesen völlig zerstörten
Wohnblöcken wie klein ist dieser
Ausschnitt wenn wir an die Großstadt an
die Hauptstadt Kiew denken oder sehen
wir solche Bilder der Zerstörung
mittlerweile ja überall quer durch die
Stadt
nein man sieht diese Bilder noch nicht
zum Glück überall und an jeder Ecke es
ist so das ist in Teilen passiert also
an diesem Wohnhaus ich zeige euch mal
wie die anderen Wohnhäuser hier aussehen
Jade äh buildings hier die sind
weiterhin sozusagen nicht nicht komplett
frei also da weiter hinten gab es eine
Bombardierung aber das ist sozusagen der
Normalzustand der Stadt hier im
Wohnviertel nur auch wenn ihr diese noch
unbeschädigten Gebäude sehen können kein
Patricia das ist ja das wovor die große
Angst vorhanden ist das sozusagen das
großflächig passiert in der ganzen Stadt
und das ist die Sorge die Angst und auch
der Druck der damit auf Präsident Selens
gelegt nämlich dafür zu sorgen dass
dieser Krieg aufhört dass dafür zu
sorgen dass es irgendeine Art von
Verhandlungsergebnis gibt aber das ist
für ihn auch gleichzeitig so schwer denn
seine Bevölkerung so scheint es
zumindest will auch nicht akzeptieren
dass man einfach die Ukraine als solches
aufgibt und das ist eine schwerer
schwere Gratwanderung ein schweres
moralisches Dilemma was dazu führt dass
wir solche Bilder wahrscheinlich noch
häufiger sehen werden
dort in Kiel vor einem Wohnhaus das
wieder einmal getroffen wurde wieder
einmal ein ziviles Ziel dort in der
ukrainischen Hauptstadt danke dir für
deine Berichte